well
, an expansion of lanes is expected
on interstate 15 south hello how are you and
cheers andrés gonzález with his brief
news nao in spanish the
governor of nevada skip 6 solac
contacted the governor gabino of
california to talk about this change
of five miles south on the
highway that connects nevada with
california which would add a lane
for drivers traveling from the
neighboring state of california would pay 12
million dollars its governor
explained that this money comes from
already existing funds this is a
temporary solution that would improve the
safety while it would make it easier
to get around
and my snowy nose joins other
organizations in the valley to organize
a vaccination clinic for children
this afternoon it will be at the
rafael rivera community center located on stuart and
mojaba starts at 3 in the afternoon and will
extends until 7 pm in addition
to cob vaccine and
health specialists too  they will offer
the flu vaccine
you do not need to make an appointment nor is it
required to present health insurance for
more details you can visit our
page of luís now dotcom the section
in Spanish or our social networks in
news 8 nn
and the Christmas walks are back
in  the chris archer
are also back the donuts the cups of
hot chocolate among other delicacies
of the season the rides will only be from December
10 to 14 and from December 17 to 19
from four in the afternoon
until eight at night the ticket costs  4
bucks I heard only 4 bucks kids
under 2 are completely
free
let's see what the weather is going to be like this
week we'll have slightly cooler temps
with some clouds passing through we'll
stay in the 60's for the
rest of the week with a chance of
rain for  On Thursday and Friday
the temperatures will drop even more for the
weekend so get ready Labrie have
a nice day I greet you  da andrés gonzález
with informative hat the end is now
in spanish